hi I'm Erik Bosse and now that Game of
Thrones Season 7 is complete we're left
wondering where things are headed for
the final season how will Game of
Thrones end now based on some clues from
this past season and some things set up
in the books and my general
understanding of how stories are plotted
based off of my own crazy writing I got
some hot predictions and I don't mean to
brag but right after season 6 ended I
did one of these predictions videos for
season 7 which was surprisingly accurate
I'm gonna call it here I predict that by
the end of season 7 we're gonna see the
White Walkers tear down that wall in
fact I'll go as far to say that it will
be the closing image of the season hey
not bad
wait just don't show all the [ __ ] that I
got wrong I think next season will show
the completion of Arya's Ark and her
death uh can't win them all
with that said in case any of these
educated shots in the dark end up being
dead on for season eight boiler warning
okay first a quick update on the
timeline unconfirmed reports are saying
that season 8 will begin shooting in
October and last through August 2018
yikes that would mean the final season
probably wouldn't air until 2019 but
that also means the scripts for season 8
almost certainly have not been written
yet yes the season has rumored to have
been generally outlined at this point
but any leaked detailed plot summaries
that claim to know who says what to whom
in each scene are probably just
fanfiction either way it sounds like
season 8 will be composed of six
episodes maybe each being like an 80
minute movie that's a lot of stories so
let's start with my first prediction of
what will happen during that season
cities will burn and they'll burn blue
the night King and it's Dragon will
continue on this path of destruction
from the wall to lay waste to the major
cities of Westeros I mean guys that's
the promise the show made with these
final images of season 7 the wall
falling is like a dam bursting nothing
is safe and yeah the night King doesn't
have any of the moral conscience that
Daenerys has like he doesn't need to win
over the hearts and minds of Westeros he
could just go about killing and
converting them the old way now as for
where he'll go next past episodes have
given us a few hints like this season 7
premiere if they breach the wall the
first two castles in that path are last
path and car hole now we've never seen
last hearth and car hold on the show
before so I feel like seeing them get
destroyed wouldn't be too cathartic I
feel like with six episodes left they're
gonna spin that visual effects money on
new key and some more familiar places so
actually let's look back at the last
words that John spoke to Ed at Castle
black yeah I think Castle black might
actually be the night Kings next move
beyond that things probably aren't
looking too good for Winterfell but I
don't think it'll go down without a
fight more on that later then also in
season six brands mysterious three-eyed
raven visions included this shot of a
dragon shadow over the roofs of King's
Landing now every other image from that
vision was accounted for and even if
this was a shadow of Daenerys dragons
when she recently arrived at the dragon
pit summit last episode I think we would
have seen this shot but we didn't so I
think this shadow will end up belonging
to the night Kings dragon as they
destroyed King's Landing
this show has been teasing us with an
attack on King's Landing since the
beginning
Stannis's failed invasion all the recent
preparations for the siege and I think
the final act of Game of Thrones will
turn this familiar sanctuary upside down
I don't like how the final battle of the
Harry Potter series went down in the
Hogwarts castle school that would turn
the red keep into that Harrenhal like
ruin that Daenerys saw on her vision in
season 2 no it wouldn't look exactly
like that because remember Cersei
replaced that seven-pointed star window
with a Lannister lion and literal but
this is a general idea the other city I
think might burn is Old Town Ebro sand
those other maesters seemed pretty
arrogant about the threat of the White
Walkers and a Christian boy claims to
have seen dead men on a much beyond the
wall thanks for the magical help of a
raven with three eyes and archmaester
ebro's probably shouldn't have places
bet so firmly on the wall the bull stood
through a door every winter that ever
came has ended now in my past breakdowns
I pointed out how the citadel of Old
Town might be inspired by the ancient
Library of Alexandria which famously
burned along with countless sources of
knowledge about the ancient world so I
think it could be really fun to shut up
these old maesters with the shadow of
the night
dragon kind of like those old men
playing chess and independence day if
King's Landing gets destroyed what will
that mean for Cersei let's actually move
on to my next prediction Cersei will end
tragically after going back and forth on
Cersei the ending of season six and
season seven have pretty much stripped
away all of Circe's moral finery down to
something simple and true Cersei has no
heart
she's Game of Thrones true human villain
and actually considering how closely Sur
sees life as follow the prophecy she
received as a girl the king will have
twenty children you have yeah I think
there's a good chance Circe's pregnancy
won't come to term and as sad as that
would be and you know we really
shouldn't wish for that to happen a
miscarriage would be one final thing
that drive Cersei over the edge to
become the Mad Queen now in our last
breakdown Phillip and I discussed how
Cersei and Jeannie's relationship was
inspired by Shakespeare's tragedy Antony
and Cleopatra with Cersei as the complex
Queen now spoiler alert for that 400
year old play but in the end Cleopatra
kills herself with the poison of an
aspirin remember in season two Cersei
nearly poisoned herself while sitting on
the Iron Throne with Tommen bracing for
the end I could see this Mad Queen
returning to that rock-bottom state
refusing to let the White Walkers take
her in the snowy ruins of the red cape
it's also possible that the show will
end up following through on that vow and
quar theory that Jaime will end up
murdering his sister now I went into
Jaime's possible endgame in another
video but no matter what I think Cersei
is clearly a tragic figure but I could
also see the show making her more of the
main final villain that the heroes have
to face not the night King I mean let's
be honest we still don't know what the
night King wants and he'll maybe we'll
never know like he could simply remain
this iced zombie force of nature now if
that's the case maybe the show will kill
him off early now I know that could seem
like a betrayal to the show but really
george RR martin established this series
as a political drama grounded in real
human conflict like martin has suggested
that he won eight a Song of Ice and Fire
to be different from the token Lord the
Rings model of
a war for the fate of civilization in
the future of humanity and the shocking
deaths of Ned Stark and Robb Stark and
Catelyn Stark are all part of that
george RR martin intended actions to
have consequences anyone can die and
yeah that goes for characters we
identify as pure heroes and maybe the
characters we identify as pure villains
that said I do think Game of Thrones the
series has evolved past that in these
recent seasons at least becoming more of
a series driven by divine intervention I
just think they're gonna ground it more
than we expect and bring some of this
supernatural mystery into the light and
that leads me to my next prediction
about the night King I think in the
final season the night Kings goal will
be revealed not only that I think the
show has already started to tell us ok
so just like house season 5 began with a
pre credits cold-open scene showing
Cersei as a girl learning her prophecy
I predict season 8 will open with
another flashback scene that gives us
information about the other villain of
the series the night king but in this
case it'll be witnessed by brand bran
has already witnessed past events like
the creation of the night king the Tower
of joy the wedding of Rhaegar and Lyanna
there are actually a ton of other famous
events I would love to see dramatized on
this show battle Detroit into the
tourney at Harrenhal but one essential
memory to the wars to come could be the
pact now the pact was the peace
agreement between the first men in the
children of the forest thousands of
years ago
it took place on the Isle of faces the
island covered in weirwood trees on the
gods I Lake in the middle of Westeros I
think we're gonna see this and during
the scene these ancient figures will
explain what the night came once revenge
against the children of the forest for
creating him and dooming him to a life
of torment so we're gonna see them
decide to build the wall to banish him
north of the realm praying that he never
gets powerful enough to break that seal
but yeah he will I think we're also
gonna see the children of the forest
decide to hole up on this island because
as the most recent episode made a point
of clarifying their swim no good I
actually think the decision to place
John and his crew on this island in the
middle of the frozen lake in episode six
was meant to visually foreshadow this
location in the gods eye I think this
was also foreshadowed by that scene in
Episode four with John and Danny in the
cave on Dragonstone
member they saw these cave paintings
made by the children of the forest with
images of the children in the first men
together
and notice the two symbol side-by-side
I think the bisected circle represents
the first men which could be why the
White Walkers assembled human body parts
in that pattern in the first episode and
I think the world spiral represents the
children of the forest which is why we
saw those stones laid out by the
children of the forest in that shape in
season 6
I think these markings were the children
the forest record of the pack and this
is all setting up brand witnessing the
actual event in season 8 also there was
that moment in episode 5 when the
maesters brought up the children of
course brings to mind who TV host owns
the charlatans who claimed descent from
the children of the Sonos i explained in
that breakdown who jenny of old stones
is and her connection of the children of
the forest and the ghost of high heart
character from the books and before i
move on to my next prediction the reason
we could even make this video because we
can't do all of these for free is
because our friends at audible are
sponsoring it so huge thanks to them
audible offers a wide selection of
audiobooks and podcasts and you could
get a free audiobook with a 30-day trial
by going to audible.com/veritasium the
ghost of high heart while read listening
to George RR Martin's A Song of Ice and
Fire series on audible and a new title
that I'm about to start to help organize
my thoughts and theories about the White
Walkers and the night King is Game of
Thrones the book of White Walkers again
just check out audible.com slash new
rock stars or click on the link in the
description below to start your trial
today okay moving on to my next
prediction let's talk about one of the
biggest questions that finale left us
with what's next for the love birds of
John and Daenerys now that John's about
to learn he's actually Aegon Targaryen
heir to the Iron Throne and Danny's
nephew I predict John and Danny will not
end up together okay stop crying was
weird that you wanted them to be
together I think the whole purpose of
bringing these characters together was
simply to produce a child the Song of
Ice and Fire and that these two parents
aren't really meant to grow old together
when asked about how this series would
end george RR martin promised that it
would be bittersweet now I read that as
while it may not be a straight of
tragedy characters won't end up happily
ever after and think about it Don and
Daenerys partnership has been mostly
circumstantial
they're both young leaders with aligned
goals and obvious romantic chemistry but
there's no
that they have an emotional or platonic
connection like Ned and Catelyn had or
even Jaime or Cersei have as toxic as
that is now I'm not certain if the news
of Jon's Targaryen lineage will be the
one thing to divide them I'm sure it
won't help but I don't think they're
gonna outright turn on each other either
really I just don't think both of them
will survive the final season like I
know they're the main characters it's
just crazy to me that they've made it
this far I think just like Jon's parents
didn't survive that war to see their
child grow up
I think either John or Daenerys or both
will leave this young Targaryen an
orphan okay I said stop crying I think
that's why the recent finale episode
shot their sex scene to be so dark and
foreboding with Tyrians concern reaction
I think we're meant to see the
relationship as doomed anyway I'll come
back to this since we're talking about
family members not really getting along
here's another prediction I think season
8 will finally deliver a few brother
against brother battles that they've
been promising first honestly I didn't
expect this until last episode but I
think we're gonna see the Hound vs the
mountain cleganebowl it's on brothers
it's not how it ends for you brother you
know who's coming for you also second I
think it's inevitable that the dragons
will fight each other as well drogon and
ragel versus zombie bazarian I actually
think that this battle will be the
Battle of Winterfell that I alluded to
earlier an aerial battle between dragon
brothers with Danny on drogon the night
King on vissarion and Jon on ragel
that's right he's gonna a dragon rider
specifically the dragon named after his
father Rhaegar
meanwhile in the south Cersei mentioned
that you're on gradually is bringing the
golden company from Essos along with
their elephants and I think the show is
setting up this private army from Essos
to collide with another private army
from Essos the unsullied I guess that
kind of makes them brothers really now I
would say the unsullied had better
chances in this battle you know with the
fighting for love and all that but guys
the golden company has freaking
elephants elephants now lastly among
these battles between family members the
finale made it clear that Theon Greyjoy
is Amy and to rescue his sister Yara and
yeah that Redemption plot puts them on a
collision course with his uncle you're
on now in our breakdown we went into how
the character of your on might be
inspired by Claudius from sheiks
here's Hamlet the murderous uncle who
stole the throne paranoid that his
brothers ghosts will come back to seek
revenge and I think that will happen in
the form of little Theon who like Hamlet
could engage in a bloody scuffle that
ends with both him and his uncle dead
now when we start talking about who will
survive and who won't it gets a little
hard it all depends on what kind of
thematic tone the show will want to take
in its final few episodes but I want to
reward good moral characters by letting
them survive or take a more cynical view
and reward characters who are more
dastardly and traitorous in George RR
Martin's outline for the book series
that he submitted decades ago he
originally planned for at least five
main characters to survive over the end
of the series
John Danny Tyrion brand and Arya now a
lot has changed since then the series
went from a trilogy to seven
installments and I'm assuming Game of
Thrones Season seven and eight are gonna
be pretty different from the winds of
winter and a dream of spring so there's
a good chance they won't stick to this
and other than the death predictions
I've already made in this video I'm
gonna hold off on who lives and who dies
for the rest of the cast I'll probably
do another video on that but for now
let's move on to the big question how
will Game of Thrones end but will be the
final scene now the closing image of a
television series is almost always a
huge deal it's actually why we spend so
much time in all of our breakdowns
analysing the themes and possible
symbolism of each opening and closing
image so what will be the final shot
that we see before the credits roll on
Game of Thrones will it be satisfying
now as I said before George our Martin
promised the ending would be bittersweet
some fans have speculated that the
series will end by revealing all of
these events are a story within a story
written by Samwell Tarly as part of a
new history manuscript of Westeros and
back there was a scene this past season
that might have hinted at bad what would
you call it then possibly something a
bit more poetic now the theory there was
that Sam's future history book will be
poetically titled A Song of Ice and Fire
this would be similar to that moment in
the Lord of the Rings movies when we see
Bilbo Baggins is manuscript for there
and back again which is the exact story
of The Hobbit it's also kind of like the
final scene of the sitcom Roseanne which
featured her in a twist finishing a book
that was actually just the fictional
story of the final crane
season two that show now I could see the
final season of Game of Thrones hinting
at this possibility with Sam writing all
these events in a book but I don't think
it'll be the final image so here's my
prediction the title of George RR
Martin's plan seven book is a dream of
spring and just like the winds of winter
was the title of the finale episode of
season six I think a dream of spring
will be the title of one of these season
eight episodes may be the series finale
so what does a dream of spring refer to
now someone suggested that all of the
events from the books and the show could
be a dream a vision in brans mind with
the final shot of the show being him
waking up in his bed in Winterfell
honestly I would hate that the only time
that has worked was on the sitcom
Newhart which ended up waking up from a
dream that was on the previous sitcom
use on Bob Newhart show and I guess it
also worked in that parody that Bryan
Cranston did of that with Breaking Bad
all being a nightmare from how the dad
from Malcolm in the Middle
I actually think a dream of spring could
refer to John and Daenerys child a
winter baby who sleeps and dreams of the
promise of spring and here's my out on
the limb theory on this imagine an end
to Game of Thrones final season in which
the night King and Cersei are defeated
but Daenerys dies perhaps in childbirth
leaving her baby to be cared after by
John make AAA Aegon Targaryen who gently
rocks his child to sleep as he or she
dreams of spring or even bitter sweeter
imagine both Daenerys and John have died
like maybe John won't have survived his
one-on-one combat with a knight King
which the show definitely seems to be
setting up instead this baby has to be
cared after by another perhaps Samwell
Tarly or Gilly and the final image could
be Sam singing a lullaby to lobe this
baby to sleep a song of ice and fire Oh
God that that's too violence and that is
not an appropriate story for a baby or
the bitter sweetest maybe the reason
Daenerys would die in childbirth is
because there's a complication with the
pregnancy which would be a known risk
with children who are the products of
incest and the baby is revealed to be a
dwarf that would leave Tyrion Lannister
hand to the Queen and now King regent
looking after this orphaned child a Song
of Ice and Fire who dreams of spring
huh too crazy and probably we will have
plenty of time to dream of spring
between now and 2019 and make even more
theory and prediction videos about what
will happen to the likes of Arya and the
Hound and Jorah Mormont and Brienne and
ghosts where the hell is that dire wolf
Ben what do you think a dream of spring
means will Cersei or the night King be
the bigger villain in the final season
and what do you think the night king
wants let me know your thoughts in the
comments below and tweet me directly at
da vas or at new rockstars share this
video and subscribe to new rockstars to
see all of our many other Game of
Thrones videos and if you want to help
us make more videos you can contribute
to us on patreon big thanks to all of
our donors especially Ponies start
alright thanks for watching bye